the reason for this excitement about
this map Center is is partly because of
the excitement about David's collection
which people know about it because he's
been so generous in making it accessible
through the David Rumsey org website and
because of his many talks and frankly
he's been very generous allowing others
of us to make use of those maps and
helps us demonstrate what the future is
now and what it will become soon so
there's a lot of folks out there who
have had some expectation for how this
will be a great place to come for those
who are cartography nuts the other thing
about this to realize is that David and
Abbie his dear wife and our longtime
friend are both running it about I would
say five hundred amps all the time
they're totally committed to this and
deeply involved in the planning and the
and ultimately in the operations as well
we've been partners in this in this
development I think for at least a dozen
years maybe longer and we will be
partners for a long time to come
so David and the rest of my team have
been closely involved in the planning
and they're now closely involved in
keeping an eye on the contractors and so
forth and we expect to have a grand
opening in April April all things
growing we're will be April I'm going to
say a few words about Paul soon but I
think it's now time to rial to see a
video
one of the great choice of a library
whether it's a private library or public
library is serendipity so certainly when
you come into David's library you know
you never know what's going to be on the
table that day was looking at her on the
screen and there is an aspect of that
that we're trying to replicate in the
map Center that when students come or
people come for a lecture or a scholar
comes that there'll be a rotation of
materials available to look at are there
people working in the room and somehow
you'll get a sense not just to what
you're looking at and what you came to
the map Center to look at but of all the
other possibilities the vision that I've
held for the center is that it'll be
this amazing place where people will
come to enjoy the maps as exhibits to
work with the maps as research to come
to a lecture about maps to have a class
about mapping and particularly I think
the contribution that I would like to
see the center make to map libraries in
general is on the technical side the
whole digital side to make the digital
tools like GIS and large visualization
screens really work and sing with the
physical maps in ways that furthers all
of the different things that we want to
do their centerpiece of of the center is
a very large screen it's 10 feet high 15
feet wide it can display maps that are
in their original size imagine what you
can do if you can magnify these maps but
to be able to bring that map in bring in
other maps of different time periods be
able to compare all in the same space
while at the same time turn around and
see that physical maps the Stanford
faculty is very sort of geospatially
oriented and that was thrilling to us
the idea that this collection would be
used not just by our normal beloved map
lovers and
cartographic historians but by
Americanists by linguists by
environmental historians we see students
coming in and faculty coming in
understanding that they can use spatial
information in a way to look at the
world differently and come to some
different conclusions about it one of
the things we've worked hard at is
taking the physical pieces making them
digital and then adding born-digital
information on top of that to allow
people to do this kind of analysis and
understand things in a different way
that they didn't before
Stanford kept coming out on top and our
thinking because of its commitment to
the digital which was very important to
me and Abby because this is a collection
not just of the physical materials but
currently almost 60,000 high-resolution
images and metadata and geo-referenced
images there's a whole digital
instantiation of the collection that
Stanford was quite interested in and
willing to preserve when you think about
building a collection and it's after
life after you're gone what matters the
most is stewardship and so naturally you
think about giving it to a library and
not just any library about a library
that has a dedicated preservation staff
understands preservation science and
does not just material preservation but
also digital preservation cartography
will become the visualization of data of
all types we will be pioneering a lot of
techniques some of the techniques will
work others may not work and we will
keep trying out new ideas so this in a
sense makes the center into a laboratory
which I think can be very exciting to
donors to be a part of that story
looking at maps is a way of visiting the
past that you can't in any other way as
I see David interact with maps I'm sure
he did this as a young boy that you
enter into a map and it really is its
own world and you can very easily get
lost in it well I agree completely and I
wish in my undergraduate days I had had
access to this kind of center this kind
of mapping the center can be a place
where the passion that all of us have
who love maps can be made real and can
be expressed thank you Mike I think that
video expresses very well the excitement
and commitment that Abby and I feel
towards the Stanford library and towards
the map Center and we hope that all of
you here in various ways will be drawn
into interacting with the map Center and
help with its future part of what we
want to share with you this evening in
this short talk that Paul and I are
going to do is to see this talk itself
and what we've arrayed here is an
example of the kinds of things that we
want to have happen at the center that
will be showing you physical things Paul
will be bringing out his instruments
I'll be showing you or you've already
seen some of the many maps and atlases
that are here
but also will be showing you digital
images and transformations of those
things that will further our
understanding of them so our talk is
about wayfinding and wonder which is a
great title that we're not responsible
for but that Gabrielle came up with and
that we adore as Mike said we're so
thrilled that Paul is giving his
instruments to the center thank you Paul
and as I've said to Paul it's not just
the instruments it's Paul's head he
knows so much about the instruments and
has so many stories that are so
compelling and he's going to bring those
to the center as well so we'll go
through some of this material and as
Mike said afterwards field will have a
question period and then
can also just join together and look at
things and have discussions about these
wonderful objects so we're going to do
earth sea and heavens that's the realm
of mapping starting with the earth we
have this image of Claudius Ptolemy who
was a wonderful Greco Egyptian
geographer around 100 to 150 AD Ptolemy
was obsessed with latitude and longitude
and he really established the whole
principle of latitude and longitude that
we could find things by identifying
where they were on different axes in his
geografía which really survives and here
you're seeing a page from book three it
survives as tables of places his maps
themselves did not actually survive but
starting around 1400 his maps resurfaced
and they were brought to light 27 maps
in total one of the known world and the
other 26 of localities in the world it
is thought that Ptolemy used at least
two kinds of instruments to determine
latitude this something similar to this
this is something Paul suggested to me
the Chaucer astrolabe from 1320 for that
Chaucer discusses in his treatise on
astrolabes it's quite a beautiful
amazing instrument Paul can say more
about that a little later Ptolemy also
used a fairly simple quadrant to measure
the altitude of the Sun and stars so
that he could calculate longitude
Ptolemies map of the world shown here of
on Mercator z-- version of it thought to
be one of the most beautiful had a
built-in flaw that was really quite
fortuitous he thought that the world was
eighteen thousand miles in circumference
it's actually 24 as we know so he
underestimated what Columbus who was
using
ptolemies map
was going to face as he went sailed west
he didn't if he had known that the
distance was so large perhaps he
wouldn't have embarked and history would
have been different
so maps the errors in maps can be useful
and interesting and very effecting
Ptolemies maps were also the
inaccuracies because of his knowledge of
longitude here we have Scotland bending
way over to the right because he had the
incorrect longitude for Scotland so some
of these are quite interesting later on
and you can see this on the back wall
ortelius looked back at the tall mayic
maps this is or T lets's map from 1590
showing the world of ptolemy and then
the world as it had become known from
the discoveries of Columbus and other
explorers thanks to Barry Ruderman who
is here tonight I've acquired this
wonderful atlas by Petrus berteus in it
is what happened it's sort of a paradigm
of what happened to mapping after
Ptolemies maps were lost
these are cartograms this is the Putin
jur tables which are a series of four
sheets they're eight maps they stretch
out 21 feet and they show the entire
Roman world road system but it is not in
an accurate latitude longitude format
it's it's very distorted north to south
so it shows us Rome here it is stretched
out completely but it's a very useful
tool it identifies five thousand places
and is a major source of information on
on the Roman world to my eyes it reminds
me very much of some of our 20th century
information visualizations such as Harry
Beck's
amazing map here of the London subway
system from 1933 where he simplified the
whole
in order to make it more readable and
understandable with the rediscovery of
Ptolemies works in the 1400s
european mapping returned to a more
mathematical system of measurement and
projection these are maps as I mentioned
by ortelius here's our T Lisa's world
map from 1570 good now see that America
is part of the known world and we also
began to get various kinds of trees on
mapping instruments so this is Leonard
Diggs map sorry his book which has a
wonderful title panto met Rhea and it's
his delineation of his theodolite that
he invented and their wonderful
illustration showing the kinds of
triangulation that would become common
and is the source of so many of the maps
that you see here so many of the
rationale rationalizations looking
forward particularly to the cassini maps
in France this is a book I don't have
but I'm I'm looking for I'm looking at
berry because I just discovered it sort
of working on this talk and I was
fascinated by it
starting in 1830 we're now moving ahead
into the 17th century we start to see
the the Dutch publishers make these
extraordinary atlases and maps and this
is the first atlas made by Willem Blau
1630 called the atlas appendix you can
see that he celebrates the
rationalization of tools of mathematics
he's showing his army Larry sphere the
calipers the globes the plows his vow
himself and later his son Joan Blau were
very close with Tycho Brahe he who was
the wonderful astronomer Danish
astronomer and in Joan blouse atlas my
your there was
published later around 1665 it shows bra
haze amazing estate his observatory and
his instruments here this is his army
Larry sphere his sextant his quadrant so
this is the rise of these instruments
beginning to have real effect all that
said there was still a very common
practice maps copied each other and it's
one of the ways that knowledge was
transferred so plows map of Virginia
that appears in this atlas appendix 1630
is a marvelous map obviously Blau
himself did not travel to Virginia so he
used the best map at the time this is
John Smith's map from 1612 when you
compare them together you can see that
Wow took everything that Smith had and
more so this copying of maps was was
very very common getting closer down to
the earth and a little later in the
century 1675 John Olga B did this
marvellous atlas called Britannia it's
over here behind me which you may want
to see after the talk it also celebrates
the tools of survey but he uses these
amazing ribbons to do strip maps of all
the roads in Britain and Wales at the
time and in order to keep the ribbons
parallel you can see he changes the
compass orientation of each map so North
shifts on the different ribbons these
are just marvelous Maps again the title
page of that particular map shows the
pedometer that they used and also
they're the staff which Paul is a Jacob
staff along with the compass and the
diopter to get their position you can
see it up close here
again on the title page all of their
various tools similar to what Paul has
laid out here switching over to Italy in
1691 an extraordinary geographer
Vincenzo
Coronel II in his Atlanta Veneto just
festoons his title pages with survey
instruments see all of these carnelli
was an amazing geographer I think the
Atlanta Veneto went on to 13 volumes and
this is his map of the Arctic which is
one of my favorites it shows all the
discoveries that were made plus it's
just graphically quite quite stunning
then we move into the 18th century and
sort of the height of this triangulation
of mapping rationalization we have the
four generations of the Cassini family
in France this is their hundred and
eighty-two sheet map of France which is
on the back table the sheep near
Marseilles they use triangulation
through the entire country these this
particular map shows all the
triangulation points the Paris
observatory was the zero was the prime
meridian they did amazing to me the
engraving is extraordinarily beautiful
and the accuracy is is amazing too we've
geo-reference the entire set and it
actually geo-referenced very easily
everything just went clutch um there was
very little distortion because the
original surveys were so sound here are
all hundred and eighty two sheets joined
together this is the map that is along
the back wall of the area around
Marseille and the Durant's River here
in 1790 the dispute between the
observatories at Greenwich and at Paris
was finally solved by the British and
the French agreeing to shoot triangles
across from Dover to Calais
Dunkirk the it's sort of an exciting
moment in survey because these two
triangulations of two countries go click
on and they finally knew the exact
difference in degrees between the Paris
observatory and Greenwich so it was one
of these seminal moments so to aid this
process they used this monster
theodolite
called the Ramsden theodolite was 36
inches across 200 pounds in weight it
had its own carriage with special
Springs and it was used for 60 years in
the Ordnance Survey all over the UK it's
just an amazingly accurate tool it was
dragged up mountains into valleys here's
our own version of that joining of the
surveys this is we put this into Google
Earth the Cassini survey then we put the
Ordnance Survey the British survey in
and here's that here's our own little
version of the joining of the - skipping
ahead finally to the 19th century into
an atlas right behind me here this is
the king survey the Clarence King survey
from 1876 it's quite an amazing survey
it you it basically created five Maps it
was not like some of the other Great
Western surveys the wheeler surveys with
its hundreds of maps but these are very
specially done they go from Reno to Salt
Lake here they are joined together the
topographic sheets and the geologic
sheets this is King and his group out in
the field around Reno during the survey
they lived well they lived on the
railroad they had their own railroad car
they had their horses so they
could return and clean up after they'd
been at camp for a while here they are
on the left with a the odd light
shooting from one of the mountains and
on the right with the plane table here's
one of my favorite sheets because it's
an area that Abby and I know well this
is around Pyramid Lake topographic
survey here's the geologic survey
overlaid on top this is the area around
Gerlach many of you probably know where
Burning Man will be going on in a matter
of a week actually in the upper right
corner of this map so moving over to
Paul Paul's gonna start with one of the
great compasses originated in the
western US the brunt encompass all says
that even today the Brunton is an
essential part of the survey toolkit of
geologists it is so true so David
Brunton was a Canadian geologist and he
got tired of carrying heavy equipment in
the field with them and so the heavy
equipment there I can't quite actually
if you can me that black name right here
yeah that it would typically carry
something like this it would be on a
staff and it weighs a lot and Brunton
had a better idea and he said I will
compress everything a geologist needs
for quick field survey into a single
object so this is serial number 404 so
probably from about 1890 96 and what's
remarkable about it and this one
belonged to a gentleman who was doing
mind prospecting in Alaska and Argentina
back at the turn of the century this is
my personal Brunton that I used in the
field and what's interesting about it is
if you look at them up close how little
has changed
there's induction dumping damping on it
so it's a fancy feature makes the needle
settle down but what's really amazing is
this is still a fixture of geologists
and if anybody ever had a child who was
a majoring in G
ecology this was the mandatory Christmas
present to to carry around but that era
that David was talking about of the
Kings survey and beyond and really the
turn of the century was the great era of
mapping in California for geology and
the like there's one gentleman Tom
Dibley who mapped more of California
than anyone else before since and did it
with instruments like that they also
carried in the time of King he probably
carried one quite like this this is a
pocket sextant box sextant
as actually was my personal sextant I
used I this is the first instrument I
got when I was an undergraduate doing
field research in southern Mexico and
was using it to study alignments of
Mayan ruins and he would carry that and
of course you're not by the water so to
use a sextant you need a horizon this is
a wonderful late Victorian artificial
horizon that you would carry this and
you had everything you needed Alexander
von Humboldt waxed poetically about Box
sextants saying it was the perfect thing
that the exact quote was very useful for
travelers when forced in a boat to lay
down the sinuous ''tis of a river or
take angles on a horseback without
dismounting so you know this is you know
if you are planning a long trip up the
coast my advice is carry a box X then if
the batteries die on your GPS it'll
it'll save you back to you David
so we'll turn to the sea but as we go to
the sea we'll go back to a map of land
that was very very important in the way
that the sea was mapped and that's
Mercator map of the world from 1569
on what we now call Mercator projection
but at the time it was just his map his
map and then as it was modified in 1599
by by right by right allowed the what we
now know is he scaled the distances
based on latitude that was the problem
with Mercator SMAP is the issue the
distance has changed of course as you go
north
but these innovations enabled more
accurate sea charts because now Mariners
could plot a course on a chart and it
would cross all of the meridians at the
same angle so they would actually get to
where they were going it seems obvious
to us today but this was a big big deal
so this resulted in charts and here's an
example from Peter who's a Dutch map
maker and chart maker from 1667 this is
his french edition of his atlas but
here's his chart of virginia and of
course it includes New York and the area
around Boston and we see the wonderful
locks of drums the rum lines these were
the ways they could now plot straight
courses because of the Mercator
projection here's also Glenn isn't with
us tonight
but Glenn McLaughlin I wanted to
remember him with this is his signature
map of it's on the cover of his book
about California as an island and it's
it's all of those of us who love
California this we think it's going back
to this
and it's an extraordinary map so Peter
hooses Atlas was really not an atlas to
take to see it was so elegant so
beautiful it's quite expensive rather
people would take to see something like
this Atlas this is van Colin's wonderful
Atlas and you could its here and you can
see it you can see that it's definitely
head the wear of its blue-backed and
it's quite simple and the Van Cortlandt
family produced atlases in the late
1600s early 1700s they produced some
gorgeous sea atlases as we know but they
also produced this whole run of just
workmen like ocean atlases for the huge
Dutch sailing trade that was going all
over the world and those are the covers
the problem that that they had with
accuracy related to longitude of course
latitude they could measure at sea
fairly well longitude they didn't have a
good luck with longitude they would take
clocks but clocks were not accurate
enough so here we have the productions
in the period from 1730 to 1773 of John
Harrison used this extraordinary clock
maker Xander knows more about and than I
do because it relates to the long now
clock and the making of clocks but this
is his h1 which is first pendulum clock
it was tested it was fairly fairly
accurate but not accurate enough so he
moved on to h5 which is actually based
on a pocket watch and this is what
became the clock that really made the
measurement of longitude possible you
understand what they were doing is that
they wanted to have the hour of the
place they left they wanted to be able
to track that on their journey then they
would see where the Sun was and know it
was noon where they were but back where
they left if it was London it might
be three o'clock so they knew the
rotation of the Sun and then he could
figure out where they were it's quite a
simple thing to us now but it was very
important so many ships crashed into the
headlands of Cornwall because they
didn't know where they were and that's
why they created the competition for
this clock as it was once that was
established moving into the 18th century
this atlas that is here part of it one
of the volumes is here on the table by
JN Bella it's from his two volume
hydrograph efj fronts awaaz it's an
atlas of charts of the whole world again
he celebrates and the cartouche all the
instruments that they use the plain
table etc etc our set also includes a
third volume this Atlas fronts waz which
in which we found an extraordinary thing
and out just we found this pen the
Francois atlas had never been used for
200 years in the pen was just tucked in
to one of the charts and it when we
started putting the whole story of the
atlas together we realized that what had
happened the atlas came to me through a
London auction and the atlas had been
captured in a battle and this is the
annotation by the owner WP Williams he
captured it in a battle off the coast of
brittany off the island of aschoff on
nova on August 10th 1780 he had a battle
with the French frigate the nymph and
the British were the victors in this the
French captain was killed the ship the
friendship was captured and they
captured these three atlases they
considered the atlases so important they
were like you know tools of war so they
kept the atlases and then they passed
down through Williams family and then
came to me to
but what we think is Williams never used
the French volume it's sat undisturbed
and the pen we think is the French
captain's pen and he made these notes on
the chart here on the day he died
showing his route over to the battle so
these are the kinds of things that just
gets our hair what little we have left
of it standing up and exciting and it's
all part of the provenance of and the
story of these amazing books the quality
of the engraving here that Belen did is
exceptional and finally ending on this
chart which is sort of dear to Paul it's
a enemy its chart of Tomales Bay done in
this was made in 1873
it was 1878 it was originally surveyed
by George Davidson in the 1850s and
there's a note here from Davidson saying
January 9th 1857 earthquake and he's
written this note at the bottom you'll
see right after the San Francisco
earthquake of 1906 so he's looking back
almost 50 years when he was a young man
he was surveying on Tomales Bay and he
says that there was great shaking and
then all of a sudden thousands of dead
fish came to the surface of the bay and
that it was a result of a huge amount of
underground gases going up and killing
the fish quite a story Davidson Paul
will comment on Davidson and his role
I'll just say that this chart also is
interesting because it's the beginning
of electro typing where ad base and and
his survey team actually began to move
away from engraving and to this much
cheaper but very very accurate and you
can see elegant elegant stuff that they
were able to do and it brought the cost
of charts down and made them widely
available
so I'll turn it over to Paul he'll start
with the Headley octant sure you know it
the risk of stating the obvious
maps and instruments have a symbiotic
relationship you get a better instrument
that leads to more accurate Maps more
accurate maps create greater demand for
more accurate instruments and really
interesting transition happened starting
1699 up to about 1800 so as its it it's
a little open to question but the
general consensus is that Isaac Newton
was the first one to conceive of a
double reflecting device for taking
elevations in the sky which is and this
is an example of such a device this is
called a Hadley octant and it's called
an octant because that arc is 120
degrees or 1/8 of a circle and it has a
couple of fairly a revolutionary
features so think of for Ptolemy using
that quadrant or or an Arab astronomer
trying to measure the elevation of a Sun
with an astrolabe looking down the bore
the instrument straight at the Sun with
no filters the double reflecting device
allowed them to put filters in place
that made the job a little bit easier
and what's interesting is Newton
invented as the story goes the idea of
the double reflecting device others
you're taking one reflection off the
horizon and one reflection off the
celestial body and moving this arc to
bring them together and he told us to
William Halleck of comment Fame and also
Hallie did some very fine maps and how
he kept it a secret inexplicably for
about 30 years and it was in
independently developed by Hadley who
was born in the late 1600s leading to
them in 1750s and this is this is one of
his devices the problem was when they
started getting up against longitude
there was a difficulty that there in
fact it is possible to calculate
longitude without a clock you never how
many people here read Davos Oh Belle's
book No okay so fabulous book wonderful
person
stuff but there are some details there
was a method called Lunars and and you
calculate longitude via Lunars by
measuring the distance between the moon
and a known navigational star and then
you take the elevation that gives you
your latitude and you consult the table
it a little inconvenient if the moon's
not up you know you can't see well the
problem is it turns out the Hadley with
its 120 degree of Arc wasn't you need
about 140 degrees to take a decent lunar
unless you're very lucky and so what
happened was this device was displaced
in 1791 by this device this is George
Adams Sexton very early sextant and you
can tell because of this frame it turns
out we as we understand in Silicon
Valley never buy the low serial number
of anything that frame looks lovely but
it led to unacceptable movement on the
arc and so they went to a different
style so these are only made for about
three years but it's also interesting
because the arc on this how many people
have heard the name Jessi Ramsden
Ramsden was a famous instrument maker
David showed a picture of his yacht
alight earlier he came up with a
dividing engine that allowed them to cut
these scales much more precisely and
that plus metallurgy allowed them to
shrink the measuring device down to this
size and also extend the arc to 140
degrees so they could actually do Lunars
with it but what's really fascinating is
this device you would think oh well this
absolutely would replace this over time
these coexisted for a very long time
Harrison built his his fifth clock you
know in the 1700s but it was not until
eighteen after 1800 that those darn
clocks were cheap enough that mere
mortals could take him on their ship the
Royal Navy at one point only had two of
them in the entire Navy so they would
carry both of these devices and this was
the everyday device for measuring sun's
altitude and this was brought out on
special occasions when it was absolutely
needed for the accuracy and the price
difference so in in the 1850
device like this would it cost about two
shillings 52 pounds 15 which was
slightly more than an entire year's
salary for a servant in in an estate
this one when it came out was 15 pounds
20 and a footman in 1790 or a coach
driver would have earned between 15 and
20 pounds for an entire year so you
could see why this was well taken care
of
and this one probably this one and most
certainly this one never went to see
this probably belonged to some you know
wealthy one-percenter in in the 1790s
and it was hanging around in this state
and somebody finally tripped over and
said you know we need to get get that
thing out of our garage which by the way
I'm really grateful to Mike and David
because I really want to get this crap
out of my garage too
the third one though is this cute little
device and it goes straight to Davidson
this is a Quinton so again you know a
sextant you can do the divisions and it
only goes it goes up to a full 190
degrees it has no filters on it you
don't use this to look at the Sun and
has a funny little angle a handle that
allows you to hold it horizontally this
is what a like what Alexander von
Humboldt was talking about it's a device
for precisely measuring horizontal
angles and it is exactly this one
belonged to the British hydrographic
office around 1900 and Davidson would
have used a Quinton exactly like this in
making those marvellous maps of the
California coastline so it was used for
mapping and it was also hughes to keep
your ship from going up on the rocks
back to you sir
so we'll end with the heavens on the
wall here and also the cube itself are
examples of igneous guests on parties
who created a series of six of these
very beautiful star and constellation
maps in the late 17th century all six
map plates joined together to make a
unified view of the heaven as seen from
the earth so it's a geocentric mapping
which is quite unusual I'll also be
showing the Italian Cassini globe here
which is more typical the God's eye view
which is God way outside the universe
the map maker is God of course no
coincidence parties are very special
he's done these in the mnemonic
projection so it's a bit odd so you know
it's deaf it's the universe as a cube so
here are his face is all joined and
you'd be viewing these from the inside
but the virtue of it is that like the
Mercator map any straight line gives
accurate measurements that's the virtue
of the mnemonic projection
they're also just stunningly and
smashingly beautiful they think that
they're based on Glaus globes
it's celestial globes we have
manipulated them we've geo-reference
them we we've visualized them in various
ways
here we've reprojected them in GIS so
this you can see how different this is
extending the mnemonic out to the
horizon here we've changed to a
spherical projection here this is a
wonderful odd Berg house projection I I
just like it I've never
understood what it was used for but it's
quite stunning and here we have it in a
Mercator projection and we also when we
put it in Mercator then we were able to
put it into Google Earth with my dear
friend Bruno Bowden who is somewhere
here and yeah there you are Bruno Bruno
remembers way back when we we put these
in Google Earth we also Bruno put them
in Google Sky we put this the Cassini in
Google Sky although we had to flip it
we had to reverse it because it was
God's eye and in sky we were looking at
it from the earth so I think many of the
Google users were wondering why the
letters were backwards we had to explain
so here's the Cassini this is Giovanni
Maria Cassini no relationship of the
French Cassini's he was a wonderful map
maker and globe maker flourished in Rome
about 1780s 90s
1800 these globe Gore's appeared not
only in globes that he made but also in
his huge atlas this nuovo atlante in
three volumes
he was obviously inspired by Cassini he
comes a hundred years later I'm Sue's me
by Coronel II he comes a hundred years
later but yes that same expansive
geographical approach he writes a whole
chapter on how to make Globes
which is unusual at that time he drew on
the star catalogues of Flamsteed and
lequel he added two new constellations
we also took these globe Gore's
and we geo-reference them after they
were scanned so here were able to
reproach and then finally we put them
into a virtual world this is my avatar
mr. Darwin map Darwin in the Rumsey map
islands in
Second Life and this is hey Ori that we
made and we wrapped the I know this is
not deep scholarly work we will get more
serious at the map Center but you have
to be playful a little bit you know at
the same time we did another trophy you
notice the two at the back there's the
terrestrial and the celestial that mova
has made typically they were seen
together we put the terrestrial globe in
the middle and wrapped the celestial
around it and then finally we've done
this collaboration with marvel globes
which they've used our geo reference
scans there's two in the back the
terrestrial and the celestial and then
there's one large celestial here mova
loves what we're doing at the center and
whether we like it or not we're getting
there whole globe collection so if you
can imagine a room where all these
things are turning slowly it may drive
you mad but it'll be interesting so
celestial Globes and charts themselves
were as Paul and I were discussing
scientific instruments they were used
particularly Globes and they were able
to you were able to calculate all manner
of celestial phenomena from the paths of
comments to eclipses so Paul I think
it's going to start with his his carry
celestial globe you could carry on a
ship to show all of the navigationally
important stars okay so I'm not gonna
pick up the carry you can haul and do
come over and look at this stuff later
by the way one of my favorites is this
is still from Earth this is a cavalry
plane table and it was designed for a
cavalry officer to wear this on their
wrist so they could do mapping on the
fly while being shot at and you you as a
compass here so dude take a look because
it's amazing all the ingenious ways
people have tried to yeah it was the
first wearable
this this looks like a globe it's
actually a navigational instrument this
was carried would be carried on a ship
and it shows only the 50 odd
navigational stars so it was used for
planning ones night sights and then also
you know in terms of memorizing the
Stars and like and it would that's from
about 1910 but it is we talked about
this guy I bring this up so this is if
if the hadley was the beginning of
double reflecting this is one of the
first made and that was one of the first
sections made this is one of the very
last sextants ever made by the sea Plath
company the the British dominated
instrument making in the age of
Hornblower and then the Germans bypassed
them and the highest standard was plot
this is actually not the highest art of
life it was after Litton acquired them
and it was one of the last sextants made
this actually came off a u.s. nuclear
submarine was the captain's personal kit
and this little thing here is an
artificial horizon so you would plan
your sights with something like this and
they actually had these on US nuclear
subs not so nice and wood and and then
use this to take the pictures or take
take your sights and yes let's so go
into the next one so what I'm going to
kind of do is just work backwards here
there pretty soon will be no more
sextants made that's and and I wouldn't
advise buying a plot that was made after
1970 because the way we relate to this
guy is changing and it goes all the way
back to this this is a lodestone silver
bound lodestone and under the this is
the name of the gentleman I think owned
it and the Year 1791 which is
interesting that you would carry a
lodestone on a ship because compass
needles were made of soft iron and had
to be remag 'no ties periodically by
rubbing them against a permanent magnet
well in the 1750s in english gentlemen
figured out how to make permanent steel
magnets and they are
needles and they absolutely took off so
it's fascinating that someone was still
carrying one of these in 1791 and I'd
like to ascribe it to the conservatism
of mariners that well those newfangled
steel needles might work but it could
fail and just in case or you know a
personal talisman and you know this is
something from the earth used to find
one's way on the planet by referring to
the sky and that seems so so quaint and
so old but it we're poised at a moment
this is what makes especially
interesting to me about the mafroom is
that we're about to abandon the sky for
navigation GPS is ubiquitous but one of
the top priorities at DARPA and in the
Department of Defense today is coming up
with a navigational system that does not
rely on satellites and software for
obvious reasons and one of the things
we're going back to his Earth's
magnetism so this I think little piece
from 1791 nicely completes a circle
through sky to sea and back to Earth it
was a Luddite give this women another
Rumsey cocktail all right well I think
we're about done we'll be happy to have
some questions if if you like and we can
also just continue our discussions
afterwards next year we hope we'll be
able to have this kind of gathering at
the rum zmapp Center at Stanford and we
certainly hope that all of you that are
here tonight will join us in making the
center a very special place that will
celebrate maps and there are many
technologies both the old and the new so
thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
elaboration the bars open the bars Oh
Quinton yeah this would be it's an
essential triangulation tool yes
absolutely right and you should talk did
you meet Hans hustle Bach earlier you
guys should talk this is the god of
surveying instruments and you should
talk to him quickly yes it's 1/5 and
what it is is as they got better at draw
doing these arcs they could make the
instruments smaller to the cutting more
precise that they made it possible to do
that
[Music]
and my question oh absolutely
great question I'm actively looking to
collect exactly that type of material I
do you remember the aero satellite I
used to get in 1966 weekly mailings of
the black-and-white images and strips
I wish I had kept them I didn't keep
them but we're looking for exactly that
type of material because it's a big part
of the story and 50 years from now a
hundred years from now that will that
will be a huge part of the story we're
also looking to preserve GIS the
products of GIS gulino's and Selene both
know a lot about that a lot of GIS work
that's done is what we would call a
little bit throwaway and it's it's so
Stanford is so good in its library to
think about preserving the GIS tables
the databases the software itself so yes
by all means we we that's a big part of
the 20th century and that really ties to
long now foundation as well and long now
is working with Stanford and with the
map
the map Center and and Julie back here
as I'm sure many of you know for example
the original data from the Viking Lander
all that stuff collected enormous cost
can't be read because there's no longer
a machine around that can read the tapes
and besides the iron filings are falling
off so they're gonna tackle that stuff
too late for me so I we should take one
more question and Mike has last question
okay yeah Xander stand up so this is a
device that was built by a Swiss artist
in Europe Lenny
it was commissioned for this space he's
built several drawing machines the other
one that he made at a much larger scale
was just acquired by MoMA's permanent
collection but we can send kind of any
vector based information to it and we
can also sequence the meta story behind
mr. Keller that's it all right great
have a drink
so let's have a drinks and we can do
more chatting
[Applause]
[Music]